sour salty crunchy
i think it's safe to say that everybody
loves a good pickle
there's a little shop just outside of
philly that takes pickles to a whole new
level welcome to elsie's the sandwich
shop that uses pickles instead of bread
you want to try one or two or three
[Music]
my name is katherine cohen and i am the
head pickle proprietor at elsie's in
haddon township new jersey
elsies was born out of necessity our mom
is a cancer survivor and was diagnosed
with diabetes and that was something
that she was really struggling with
we decided as a family to start making
our mom
sandwiches on pickles rather than on
bread we resurrected an old family
recipe that hadn't been used in probably
a decade and we started from there
part of the process of making our lcs
signature pickles involve icing down the
curvy cucumbers adding sea salt vinegar
onions garlic and that's all i can tell
you because my mom will not be happy if
i reveal
what the recipe actually is
[Music]
thank you part of the concept with
elsies was to create a sanctuary for
people that have dietary restrictions
diabetes celiac keto gluten-free he
found that there was a need for a bread
alternative and the pickle sandwich
became very very popular
one of our best-selling sandwiches is
the elsie's famous italian which is ham
capricorn salami provolone lettuce
tomato onion
you can even get it topped with sriracha
mayo haas crushed potato chips
to bite into an elsi's signature pickle
sandwich it really is heaven it's crisp
it's crunchy it really is a fantastic
experience
oh yeah
it's unlike anything i've ever had
before
very good
our other option is a cucumber roll-up
and you can have the cucumber roll-ups
made with any sandwich topping you'd
like both pickle and cucumber roll ups
are served with a pair of chopsticks so
it's really a lot of fun to eat
we offer
complimentary pickle brine while you're
at the shop you're welcome to as many
pickle juice shots as you can handle
[Music]
people take a pickle pilgrimage to come
here they have rerouted flights they
have driven from toronto canada to
experience lcs
it makes me feel awesome because
at the core i'm really an old lady and i
just really love to feed people
[Music]
you